It's the hilarious Pamela Adlon.
Yes.
Thank you.
(audience cheering)
I can't believe I'm here.
I don't know what we're doing.
Let's go. Sous-chef.
Okay, let's go, all right.
Rosie, you are in the driver's seat.
All right.
Yeah.
I will say on your show, Better Things,
you do cook a lot.
Yes.
And you cook in real time on the show, right?
Yeah, we cook.
Like you chop and like cut fingers.
And like you cook real.
The whole thing.
Roll on the cut. Roll on the blood. All of it.
Yes.
That's, I mean,
I don't know what kind of bizarre, sick, funny,
hilarious thing we have,
but everything is like, get it, get the blood.
Let's film it.
Yes.
And Rosie, you're going to you teach us
your white fish casserole recipe.
Yes, okay.
Take it away.
All right so,
this recipe I stole from somebody and made it better.
(Pamela laughs)
(audience laughs)
That's the way to do it.
That's the only way.
You get 15 to 20.
These should be raw tomatoes.
You skin them, you deceive them and you chop them up.
You can take two big Spanish onions and you do the same.
You put it in here.
You saute them, until it comes down.
Here's my secret ingredient, why it's better.
Cinnamon baby, hola.
And so you're gonna put this like this all throughout.
And I know it sounds weird,
but it's gonna taste so, so good.
You let that cook down and then you take white wine.
Where's the white wine?
Here.
Is it this?
Yeah. And by the way,
you're going in.
I do this?
Is it white wine?
Yeah, you get in the demo,
you're the cook.
Yeah, this is white wine.
Oh my, my God.
So you pour
the white wine in here.
White wine.
And you let it cook down
Cook down
a bit.
Right.
While this is going, you're gonna start
with your red potatoes.
You're gonna boil them, slice them, olive oil them.
Is this olive oil?
Yes it is.
Okay.
You're gonna olive oil them like this
and put salt and pepper like this,
and then you go like that.
So, okay, and then when that's done and you mix it all up,
right?
You're gonna take your fish.
You're gonna salt and pepper your fish,
very, very, very, very generously.
Right?
Flavor.
And you're gonna put a lot of salt on it like this.
Okay.
And then you're gonna take the lemon juice, a whole lemon,
and a quarter cup of what you gonna call it?
Olive oil?
Olive oil.
And you're gonna stir it up and see what happens?
Emulsifying.
It gets like that.
It gets emulsified.
Emulsified.
And then you're gonna pour it all over the yummy, yummy.
Look at that. Look at that. Fattening, yeah, love it.
Okay.
(Pamela laughs)
You put there like that.
You let that sit and now you're gonna start layering,
as if it's a lasagna.
And what you're gonna do.
Right.
You're gonna take one scoop
of the mixture, your sauce mixture.
You put it on the bottom.
Oh, okay.
Right? So now you're gonna layer the potatoes on, right,
in your thing.
You're gonna take your fish flounder.
You could use flounder.
I like flounder, but you could also use orange roughy.
But flounder's better.
Flounder, I love it.
Okay, and so-
Food with the letter Q.
Yes, foods that begin with the letter F or O, R.
Yes.
Okay, so you layer this like that,
and you're gonna put another layer of this.
Mix spice.
Right.
Then you're gonna take bread-
Should this be bubbling
this much, Rosie?
Yes.
Okay.
This is panko,
but you could use Italian-seasoned breadcrumbs
that makes it even better.
And so, you're gonna go like these generously.
You do three layers of this until like your casserole dish
is finished and full.
And you're gonna go ahead and put it in the oven.
You're gonna put it in the oven at 425,
and you're gonna let it bubble up, until it's bubbled up,
until it comes out like this.
Can you get the other side with me Rosie?
(audience cheering)
Oh, it looks good baked in the oven, yeah baby.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Okay.
That is so gorgeous,
by the way.
And it tastes so good.
Oh, we have to do plates? Okay.
Did I do this wrong?
Do you put the potatoes on the thing?
You got to keep
Are we finishing this?
layering it.
Forget this,
it's already made.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, yeah.
Ready?
Cheers.
Yeah, cheers.
Thank you so much.
I can't believe, this is crazy.
Here's to women.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's to women.
(audience cheering)
That's exactly right.
Perfect moist. Perfect.
It's so good.
I feel like I won a contest.
You get to cook with Rosie Perez and Drew Barrymore.
This is crazy.
This is perfect.
And you don't even notice the cinnamon, but it gives that,
a little different something.
The cinnamon's a nice,
chef's kiss.
So good.
So far, it's good.
This is so good.
If I should say so myself.
(audience laughs)
But I will say nothing compares
to getting to be with the two of you.
This is a dream come true.
It's a surreal, awesome dream of perfection.
I thank you both for this moment.
I agree.
I thank this show for
creating moments like this,
and Rosie Perez.
You can get this recipe on TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com.
And the season two of The Flight Attendant
premiered last week,
and you can catch new episodes every Thursday on HBO Max.
(upbeat music)